hello today we're going to look at Muma
linear time sequence modeling with
Selective State Spaces by Albert goo and
Tre da I know I'm a bit late on this
paper uh but I still thought I'd give it
a look and excuse the lack of face cam
today I know it's a tragic loss to not
see my face while doing these reviews I
hope you can survive it uh so Mamba has
been really big uh hailed as a poten
itial competitor to Transformers uh has
better scaling property scales to really
long sequences and so on and yeah I
wanted to know what it is and I wanted
to know essentially two things like how
does it differ from all the other stuff
that exists today uh because there
there's so much stuff for example there
are so there are the
Transformers and those obviously have
their advantages and problems then there
are on are like rnns like recurrent
neural networks and then there are these
you know State space models like S4 or
something like this and there's always
interesting tradeoffs between all of
those notably um what will see is in the
Transformer you have if you have a
sequence of stuff you have attention
that's essentially anything can look at
anything else and if you have causal
attention if I look at this input I'm
able to selectively look back at another
input and sort of use that in the
computation uh of the next layer here
okay so a Transformer is able to
dynamically and selectively look at
individual elements of the past and
address each one individually but
obviously you have a problem with that
so the problem with that is that you
have like L squar when L is the sequence
length l squ computations or n SL or n l
squ uh memory requirements in order to
do this rnns on the other hand if you
have a sequence
there they if you consider this um this
particular input and you want to compute
the next layer you can only look back
one time step in fact you can't even
look at the last input you what you will
do is from each input you will compute a
hidden state so there's going to be some
sort of a box here and you will update
the box and then the next thing will
come and it will update the box and then
the next thing will come and it will
update the box and so on so you're only
allowed to look at the last box and the
current input if you want to decide what
the next box here should be and from the
box you obviously then compute the the
outputs so this is super restrictive in
that you can only ever look at the last
hidden State and the current input in
order to compute the current output and
the next hidden state but also also this
essentially scales to infinite lengths
because it instead of having you know
this much requirement of memory it only
has actually it doesn't even it it has L
computation so you compute as many
elements as you have right uh but then
it the memory requirements are really
they're really all of One they're really
only how big is the hidden State and how
big are are the inputs and outputs now
if you want to do back propop here
that's when it becomes you know a bit
more iffy then you will actually have to
remember the whole sequence of
intermediate values in order to back
propagate so ornin use a thing that's
called back propop through time and I
know I know this is super old school and
before most of you were born but again
consider the thing where you compute the
hidden State out of the last last hidden
State and the current input you compute
the next hidden state from that and
eventually you'll have some sort of
output let's say the whole sequence only
has one output you can do this with many
outputs too but what you want to know is
well how does the weights that compute
this particular um transition here or
this particular one how should I change
that because I have some sort of loss
over here well you need to back propop
through all of these computations so
through all of the comput
that generate the hidden States from
each other and then back through this
computation in order to do that that's
called back propop through time and
because you com you back propop through
so many time steps this is often either
prohibitively expensive memory-wise or
you'll just get this Vanishing or
exploding gradient problems because
essentially uh you have operation upon
operation upon operation which are often
multiplications Solutions to that are
things like the
lstm um that have built-in gating
mechanisms but the important part to
know is there is a hidden State and that
goes through some trans so there is a
function and the function of the next
hidden state t +
1 depends on the last hidden State and
the current input let's t + one some
yeah and this function here can be
pretty much anything in an lstm it's a
complicated gating thing in a simple
recurrent Network it's just I multiply
the last hidden state by some weight and
then this by some weight but it is a and
then and then I add an on linearity or
something like
this now what about the this S4 type of
thing and that's where this paper starts
off this paper starts off by saying hey
look these these uh State space models
they've been pretty we've built some of
these and they have some nice properties
what are those nice properties the nice
properties are that they essentially are
an RNN essentially
but when they have a
sequence and uh a sequence of inputs
they can essentially compute all of the
outputs if there are multiple outputs or
that single output over here in one
swoop so they can essentially compute it
like Zoom um in one big swoop and so if
they have all the inputs uh they can
just formulate this as a convolution
operator and there are multiple reasons
why that's the case but um two main
reasons first reason there is no
nonlinearity going from the last hidden
state to the next hidden state right so
that this this is a completely
linear uh transition if you will I'm
we'll we'll go a little bit into what I
mean by this obviously here um here some
kind of X is coming in and that doesn't
necessarily need to be linear but sort
of the backbone of this going through
time from hidden state to Hidden state
are linear
computations um so no
nonlinearity involved in that that what
does that what that will mean is that
essentially the whole this whole path
here this whole back prop through time
thing is going to be at least the path
that goes back the hidden States until
it you know branches off into the
individual elements that is essentially
one big Matrix multip like one big
linear operation and uh that is a lot
more well- behaved than if you also have
the uh nonlinearities in between now
obviously you can still have uh
exploding or Vanishing gradients and so
on so you could also um you can still
have that but it is a lot more easy
let's say than having complicated gating
mechanisms there and what it means is
that you can just kind of jump ahead to
any point that you want because you can
always you always know what the full
operation is you always have a closed
form to that um second okay what's
second uh there is no time dependence so
there's no time uh dependence of these
things and no input dependence what that
means is that the transition from State
one to state two is going to be the same
as the transition from state two to
state three now again there is going to
be inputs in these um that obviously
don't always compute the same function
but the transition between the time
steps and how you incorporate new
information is always the same so all
the matrices that are involved in here
essentially are all the same and not
dependent on the input at all and
therefore you can just kind of
precompute all of the aggregation right
here and then all you have to do is kind
of multiply in your individual inputs
from the time steps and you can just
compute the whole thing as as one big
computation so that's what we're going
to look at the question is where do the
these uh where does Mamba fit in Mamba
is an architecture that makes use of
what they call Selective State spaces
and selective State spaces
relaxes this property of s for a bit and
what I mean by that the property that
the transition from time step to time
step is independent of the input it
relax access that a little bit and
therefore it moves S4 a little bit
closer into the direction of
lsms and and but it remains it retains
this property that um the the backbone
here is computable by one swoop um and
we're going to they're going to do this
as a as a prefix sum as a parallel scan
it's it's computable as one swoop and
therefore during training it looks more
like a Transformer where you can just
compute all of the forward passes of the
whole sequence in one go instead of like
the lstm where the forward pass no
matter whether you know all the inputs
already you have to compute the forward
pass one after another so during
training it looks more like a
Transformer and during inference it
actually looks more like an like an LM
all right so we'll dive into the paper
and I just I have a few sections
highlighted not too much especially the
experimental result you're very welcome
to look at those the result is going to
be that it is a strong competitor to
Transformers so far they have not made
experiments up to the big like up to the
big Transformers and big so I I believe
theyve made experiments up to about 1
billion parameters that's obviously
really B big in conventional terms but
for language modeling uh the smallest
ones start at like 7 billion so that
remains to be seen But the scaling laws
seem to be uh promising the other thing
is that they say themselves it really
excels at when you need really really
long sequences like DNA modeling or
audio waveforms and so on um they having
a long context and being efficient with
that is probably more important than
this you know super ability to of
Transformers to focus in on individual
states all right so they say uh
structured State space models sorry have
been developed to address Transformers
computational efficiency on Long
sequences but they've not performed as
well as attention on important
modalities such as language we identify
a key weak that a key weakness of such
models is their inability to perform
context based reasoning what does that
mean they say we propose a new class of
selective St spat model right The
Selective is the difference instead of
the structured that improves on prior
work on several axes to achieve the
modeling power of Transformers while
scaling linearly in sequence
length so they say the key abil key
limitation of Prior models the ability
to efficiently select data in an input
dependent
manner again what does what does that
mean you have a previous hidden State
you have a current input and you want to
build the next hidden state t +
one what structured State space models
do is they have they'll have some kind
of par parameterized function let's call
that a and they'll have some sort of uh
they'll have some sort here let's call
that b even though
like it's it's slightly different but
and the the result is going to be that
HT + 1 is going to be equal to something
like a HT plus b x okay again not exact
representation but in
principle this and this is in ssms like
is going to be completely fixed for the
whole sequence always so you learn one
set of
parameters for you know 1 a and 1 B for
the entire model okay now this obviously
is very very different from Transformers
where a like the attention Matrix is
built dynamically at each single forward
pass you know for each single uh for
each single token you compute queries
and keys and values and therefore the
aggregation how you build the next
hidden state is very dependent on on
everything on the input on the past and
so on uh in this particular case super
fixed you can see this is even more
restrictive than something like an lstm
like in something like an lstm as we
discussed before what you can do is you
can
make this and this actually dependent on
the last hidden state so in an lstm
you'll see that the last hidden state
will be transformed into you know and
then this gives you the a matrix like in
a in some sort of a gating way and then
X will be multiplied by by a and and so
on so um I don't have an lstm cell in my
head but in an
lstm the propagation of the signals can
be dependent on the previous hidden
State and on the
input okay and and that's the difference
uh between the state space models and
like the fully like General recurrent n
networks what as what Muma is going to
do mumb is going to say we
allow the transition to be dependent on
the current input not on the previous
hidden state but on the current input
and you should already be able to see if
you do that it still means that sort of
this backbone going from hidden uh going
from hidden state to next hidden state
is going to be a fixed computation uh
given by this a matrix and that's why we
can sort of precompute it throughout all
of time because that a is going to be
fixed and not dependent on the input
although what we'll see is that in fact
how uh the uh how the input is computed
into and in the next hidden state is
going to be um influenced by the by the
input but
not by the previous hidden State okay so
I I hope I've made this clear a is going
to be dependent on the input B is going
to be dependent on the input but they're
not going to be dependent on the last
hidden state or any thing of the
past so it's kind of a tradeoff between
the state space models of the past and
recurrent neuron
networks um yeah so they they say okay
this poses a challenge for the
computation of the model all prior sorry
all prior SSM models must be time and
input invariant in order to be
computationally efficient we overcome
this with a hardware aware algorithm
that computes the model recurrently with
a scan instead of a convolution so they
say essentially we sort of make it
really fast on GPU even though we have
an algorithmically a different we have a
different Al algorithm we need to
compute something making the actual
recurrence or actually recurrently but
we do it in a way that fits really well
on Two gpus And therefore uh it's
actually in in the end it's actually
faster and yeah they make this into a
model um called Mamba uh Mamba is Mumbo
is not the same as selective State
spaces selective State space uh
are a part of Mamba uh and then combined
with some other stuff like uh 1D
convolutions and up projections and
gating that becomes the Mamba
architecture it's attention free uh
therefore it's it avoids the quadratic
bottlenecks of attention of attention
based models such as
Transformers so they say these are fully
recurrent models with the key prop
property uh for example high quality
selectivity brings strong performance
and on dense modalities such as language
and genomics I think that's going to be
the biggest sticking points so they have
recognized that you know this super
scalable thing like S4 is not really
suitable for language because you need
to be a little bit data dependent in
your transitions from you know through
the hidden States and now they say well
selectivity brings strong performance
which because they added selectivity
they added this dependence on the input
of the transition um now gives them a
bump in performance the jury is still
out whether in the future they'll say
yeah it's better but still in order to
really reach the performance of
Transformers we also need to make that
transition actually dependent on the
hidden State and at that point we're
back to essentially
lstms but it could be that the
dependence on the input just the input
um already makes them as strong as
Transformers on a lot of important
benchmarks
fast fast training and inference uh
computation memory scales linearly in
sequence length during training and
unrolling the model Auto regressively
during inference requires only constant
time per step since it does not require
a cache of previous element so there's
no key value cach FH and so like in
Transformers you literally just have to
remember the last hidden State and then
producing one additional token during
inference is just it's just two Matrix
multiplications or something like this
right so no attention no no nothing just
multiply it in and you have it and long
context the quality and efficiency
together yield the performance
improvements on real data up to sequence
length 1
million all right so this is the the the
arch Ure is a bit distributed throughout
the paper this is the The Selective
State space um part of this there's
going to be a more extensive thing here
um so the Muma architecture consists of
the part I've just shown
you but also of other things so you have
to imagine these things are going to be
layered on top of one another and then
um essentially you you'll always
consider consider the entire sequence as
one during training um so if we go in
here uh this here for example this is a
linear projection so you project up in
dimensions and you project each token
individually like in a Transformer then
you do a 1D convolution there is some
nonlinearity in there then comes that
SSM now in these two things you want to
consider the whole sequence as one
during training right however in the
projections right here they as far as I
understand go just individually over
tokens like the the MLPs in a
Transformer and then there is also this
extra mechanism right here which is a
gating mechanism like you're used to
from from other gated
architectures again this doesn't go
between time steps that's important to
note this goes from layer to layer right
so as you go up the layers the time
would be some sort the time steps aren't
even shown here there's no time
Direction in this particular diagram
there is also residual connections like
that go uh out out the way and so on um
yeah so the Mamba is an architecture
that includes this new uh selective
State
spaces that selective State space layer
looks about like this and here we now
have a Time direction right so here we
now consider how do we compute um
one token in this sequence given that we
have to accumulate this hidden State uh
over time and again we can do this
either during training where we try to
compute all of them as fast as possible
or during inference where we just do one
of these time steps so as you can see
the backbone is just going to be we have
this we multiply we mult essentially
there is
a there is a this this a matrix right
here that we're going to
use and there is the input that somehow
comes in and from these two things we're
going to produce that next hidden State
now what is all of this right here um
all of this is part of this state space
architecture how does that look there is
a technicality in here which is called
discretization now the the theory behind
State space models and and so on is was
developed for continuous time systems
and if you want to make them into
discrete you if you want to be sort of
correct you can't just uh you can't just
apply the same thing um if you do it in
the way they do it here it has some nice
properties such as I believe your you're
kind of time step in
independent uh you automatically
scale the things to the correct scaling
and so on however
whenever you hear
discretization um just you're free to
also just kind of ignore it for the
purposes of understanding what's going
on from a deep learning perspective and
from a data flow perspective I'm sorry
Albert if you're listening this must be
really offensive um and I apologize for
that uh um we can do another video where
we dive into sort of into more of the
background Behind These models and so on
um maybe not the best person to explain
that but we'll do our best to understand
kind of what's going on here on a more
high level so you have they call them
four parameters okay these are these are
matrices or vectors that just have
learnable
parameters you'll use this this here is
the S like a
parameterization
um
parameterization no sorry discretization
param
this here controls how on hidden state
is propagated forward this here controls
how much of the input is propagated into
the new hidden State and this here
controls how the hidden state is com is
processed into the uh output state so
you can see the next hidden state is
produced from the last hidden State
multiplied by what's called a bar and a
bar is simply a uh computation that
results from this discretization
parameter and the a matrix again don't
worry just consider if you want just
consider this here to be a learnable m
Matrix and this here to be a learnable
matrix and in that you can see from this
perspective this is a super duper simple
like the most plain recurrent neural
network there is without even some any
sort of nonlinearity around here you can
see this is just like a linear recurrent
neural network if you will where you
just kind of dampen in some way in some
multi-dimensional way the last hidden
State and then you add uh a a um
projected version of the input the
output is simply computed again as a
linear function of the Hidden State now
since everything is linear you can what
you can do is if you actually write this
out you actually write out I want to
compute sorry I want to compute Y3 what
am I doing I have an eraser if you
compute Y3 you can say oh well that's
just
H3 uh ah3 plus
bx3 oh but what's H3 well H3 is just ah
H2 oh sorry why is that that multiplied
by C right well that's just a H2 plus b
X2 and what's H2 well that's just a H1
plus b x X1 and so if I plug all of this
in I'm going to end up with Y3 is equal
to C * um C * a * a time
a
uh H1 let's say that's the initial
hidden State um so you can see you can
multiply this out what you'll end up
with is like you can we you'll end up
with like c a a a a uh uh B X1 c plus c
a a a b X2 and so on so plus uh c a a b
X3 so there's kind of the number of A's
just different depending on how many
time steps that particular X is in the
past but you can see I can multiply all
of this out and what that allows me to
do is that allows me to say well all of
this here is just constant no not this
all without X all of these matrices here
are just constant learnable
parameters this too this too so I can
just consider this as a vector a
dotproduct of c a a a a b c a a a
b c a a b and so on with
X1 X2 X3 and so on and this here I can
perfectly precompute you you know I just
after each learning step uh these these
are just learned parameters therefore I
can perfectly precompute that and when a
new sequence comes I just dot product it
in and I have the full output I have the
output available instantly and that's
what they do over here so you can see
they built this
kernel out of this and then they can say
well the output is simply going to be a
multiply the input as a vector by my
kernel and but boom I just have it all I
have it all available right um and
that's and that is uh why and you can
hopefully see that this is a convolution
uh so if you now if you not only want
one output but you actually want each of
the output of each of the time steps
this just results in a convolution
operation uh that you can do and that's
why the S4s and so on were so extremely
efficient because you can just compute
all at the same time all those linear
all is fixed just forward prop is one
convolution back prop super easy right
okay that's it and essentially in Mamba
we we're not we're or in structured
State spaces all we're doing is we're
making a b c and this Delta here input
dependent that's it that's the whole
that's the whole thing
um you can see this in the algorithm
here you can see see you have the SSM
here ABC go into it in fact no sorry a
bar and bar bar are computed from this
thing right here that's exactly the same
here and here but now instead of b c
this and a being just simple
parameters a is still a parameter
however everything else you can see b c
Delta is
computed from the input okay and that
means it it still means you can do the
zoom thing but the zoom thing now you
have to uh make that input dependent and
specifically specifically everything
gains a dimension so here see this has
no this is the same for each time step
this now is different for each time step
okay because each time step has a
different input and therefore or the
these things gain an extra Dimension and
that's kind of bad because that makes
them L times bigger than previously so
what do we do in order to make that
still
fast they differentiate now between two
things GPU high bandwidth memory and
what's called SRAM so gpus have two
different types of memory I didn't know
before this paper but they have the main
memory is kind of the slow memory that's
this right here that's high bandwidth
memory but that's slow even though it's
high bandwidth um well I guess high
bandwidth doesn't mean low ping all
right that's slow and then SRAM is
really small but is really fast and they
realize hey if we want to do the Matrix
multiplications these happen in this
SRAM that's essentially the cache that's
the fast stuff uh the the bulk of work
is actually moving stuff between the two
types of memory moving stuff between the
two is the slow thing and therefore
we've just made that L times bigger and
therefore we made that moving L times
slower because the multiplications
aren't that slow it's actually moving
the stuff around and therefore they come
up with a scheme where they don't have
to move as much stuff that that's
essentially it you can look the code but
um in the end it it just comes down to
that it comes down to moving stuff
around moving big stuff around is slow
and therefore they say you know instead
of computing this kind of stuff um this
kind of scan inputs in GPU um HPM we
load the parameters themselves directly
to fast s R perform the discretization
and recurrence in SRAM and then write
the final outputs back to hbm uh they
save themselves they actually don't save
themselves an L they save themselves an
n and n is the discretization expansion
Factor so during this discretization you
kind of need to expand um ex
dimensionality expand some of these
things and they save save themselves
that expansion and therefore are a lot
faster uh yeah so I'm not going to go
deeper into this except saying what they
say down here you know
um they make use of this uh reduction of
data movement plus a recomputation of
intermediate States and that results in
that the fused selective scan layer has
the same memory requirements as an
optimized transform former
implementation with flash
attention and I I believe that should
give you a good good idea of the
combination of what kind of is required
right
here so again they can still do the zoom
um except now the elements are input
dependent and therefore they have to do
the zoom differently and they do the
zoom using not the convolution because
the convolution would require the kernel
to be constant but they now do it via
What's called the prefix sum and the
prefix sum is and they call it a
parallel scan but it's essentially the
thing that computes this a * a * a * B
and then a or c a a a b and then a * a *
a * a * B and so on except now of course
all of the A's are different right so
it's now uh A1 * A2 * A3 * B3 A1 * A2
and also C C3 so you can see all of
these are now different so you can't do
like the tricks from before anymore and
what they do is a prefix sum and the
prefix sum is just the simplest form is
when you have an array like 1 5 9 2 uh
to compute the sum the cumulative sum
like 1 six uh 15 17 so that the way you
compute this in an efficient manner um
you can then you can then use this down
here for various things it's very simple
right and this is useful in a lot of
algorithm but to avoid recomputing a lot
of this stuff you can use prefix sums to
kind of precompute all of the sums or in
this case all of the multiplications of
different things together and then you
can use those and for example if you say
what's the sum from here to here you can
just subtract from 17 you can subtract
uh six or one sorry one and you can say
ah the sum here is 16 without having to
compute it again same principle goes for
how they make this here
fast the scaling laws look really scaly
uh so they the perplexity in language
modeling um and that is models trained
on the pile up to 1.3 billion parameters
scales better than all other attention
free models and there is the first to
match to perform performance of a very
strong Transformer Plus+ recipe that has
now become the standard particularly as
the sequence length grows so the jury
still out what happens at really large
scales but already at this scale this
looks quite promising um DNA modeling
and so on Mamba Superior to other things
uh yeah because long sequence lengths
are really the strength of these kinds
of models and again we'll have to see
what the exact tradeoff is going to be
whether we need to make the um the
transitions input dependent or not and
yeah you can see that uh inference
throughput on an a100 is good and
actually gets more drastic and drastic
as the batch size increases when you
compare them to
Transformers all right they have some
ablations here um it's say Mamba is a
strong candidate uh to be a general
sequence model backbone and lastly I
think I have one more highlighted
section where they discuss the
intricacies of the of the um of their
efficient implementation this section is
also good if you want to dive deeper
into this you can go into this section
especially they discuss what they
transfer how much elements they transfer
what that costs and so on so really
reducing that memory transfer and lastly
you can also dive into the code here on
GitHub if you do I invite you to look at
this Mamba simple Pi first and in fact
there the in this code base the same
thing is going to be implemented
multiple times one time for python one
time for GPU and then again one time for
uh inference where you do things
recurrently and one time for training
where you compute everything kind of at
the same time and so you you'll find the
same code written many many times in
different ways I invite you to look at
this step function right here which is
really really good and just assume you
don't have any of the extras so like
this uh causal con uh 1D update because
that gives you a good idea so see you
there's first an input projection then
there is a con 1D like a convolution 1D
convolution then um there is then then
the the parameters here are this DT they
talk about sort of projecting this down
and up and kind of putting it through a
dimensionality
bottleneck The Matrix a is is a
parameter it's just stored as log a uh
and not as a itself where was I H where
was I oh here then we do the
discretization the discretization goes
um you can see here discretization is is
done by multiplying this DT to a this DT
to B then the recurrence is calculated
the state time da plus uh x * DB so this
is the main recurrence for the hidden
State the output is calculated uh by
just multiplying the hidden state by C
and lastly there there is a recurrent
there's this gating Connection in D
which is exactly what we saw in the
paper in this architecture
diagram right right right
right here right so you have uh
projections 1D convolution nonlinearity
uh State space models with the with the
discretization and recurrence
computation uh gating pathway this is
with the Matrix D in the code out
projection and that's it all right that
was it for me for this architecture I
hope uh you got a little bit clearer on
what Mambo does how it can be used and
yeah it's exciting to go forward with
these architectures I hope you're having
a good time that was it for me Merry
Christmas and bye-bye